The joe rogan experience.
They say that infinity is so intense,
like the idea of infinity and this is
the best way to wrap your head around it.
If infinity Israel,
that means that in the universe not only
has everything that we've said in the
exact same order and the exact
same pauses in the exact same
timeframe and fuck up of
words or slip of the tongue,
it's happened exactly that
way in exactly that order.
An infinite number of times,
not just one,
but an infinite number of times that
everything that's ever taken place down to
the millisecond has not just
happened once somewhere else,
but infinite times somewhere else.
Wow.
That's how big infinity is.
That's what no end means.
That's so weird.
Like it just like when you're doing
some mundane thing like jerking off,
coming to porn.
I'm just thinking this is infinite.
It's an infinite loop of
Tj's that's happening.
Oh,
shins,
oceans of ges.
You could just see like just a
universe filled with you squirting ah,
fractal,
like literally a universe that's real
like so the sky would be absolutely filled
from horizon to horizon with
with you coming more than this.
All the come from all the Dunkin's
in all over the world at once.
Drenched the earth.
We would drown and seaman.
Oh,
how's the entire population would drown.
We would be coded in like a million
miles thick of com because if you think
about what infinity means,
how many different
Dunkin's would be coming,
there's no end to it.
So one ounce of calm equals 100 billion
oceans filled with come instantaneously
raining down upon those oceans would
be filled with more me's coming.
So not only that,
the universe itself would not be big
enough to contain the earth size.
Just from the sheer amount
of calm it was covered it.
Yeah,
it would push the
atmosphere way past the sun.
It would light the earth on fire
and turn it into a big come.
One of those fucking hush puppy.
It was a big come hush puppy
when the come got so big.
It touched the side of
the deep fryer is so big,
it touches this time and then puts the
sun out and presses out into the outer
galaxy.
That's how much come.
And then infinite amount
of people coming in.
And then some,
like some God chef would
just come and eat it.
It's just not a cooking show.
And,
and then,
you know,
he lives in another world where you're
coming on and it just goes on forever.
No,
that's how you impregnate the sun.
You fill up planet with come to the,
stop up a black hole.
We don't know what to
do about a black hole.
We're going to get an infinite
amount of Dunkin's to come in it.
Well,
it's,
you know,
mass broken down to the smallest part.
Uh,
it's not going to stop an
infinite amount of carb.
Trust me,
there's a whole other universe inside.
They're still not big enough
for infinite amounts of calm.
Sorry.
The black holes,
like what the fuck?
The black hole is like Sasha drag and
the fucking giant black cock being force
fed while she's lying on her back.
Snots going down into her eyelashes.
That's the he lived verse is
so symbolic.
So some bog of gag porn,
you're coming into a black hole,
the fucking whole of Van
and starts sputtering.
No,
that's spinning.
The spinning of the black hole absorbing
matter just gets all choked up like a
fucking,
like,
like a dishwasher disposal
system with a spoon in it.
You know when those garbage disposals,
the spoon drops in it.
You scared to put your hand
in there to try to unstop it.
Do you think,
and that's how the universe was created.
His infinite,
infinite come looped
went into a black hole.
Do you think that ever come
into a black hole in the future?
Oh yeah.
If we live long enough,
someone's going to want to do that.
They're gonna want to be the first guy,
some Richard Branson type asshole,
the first guy to show the world.
I want to inspire you that you
too can come in a black hole.
Him with a fucking black socks on.
So I always come,
he sends like a shuttle from
his pod and he's got like,
it's like a glory hole into the next
shuttle and he's wearing an aqua man t
shirt.
It's way too small and he's a little
slightly embarrassing roll of fat,
pulls out of the bar of like a little
waterfall and he's just jerking off with
his black socks on into it until
you never know until you try.
I seek to inspire.
I'm seeking to inspire
you that you too humble,
man.